and yeah thank you yes clap here we go
hey everyone thanks for joining the
virtual happy hour today yeah so here's
the challenge it's to make your very own
unique Quarantine e
using no more than five ingredients that
are already in your fridge or pantry ice
does not count and it doesn't also
necessarily have to be like a martini I
know not everybody has martini glasses
but whatever simple cocktail you can
make with the ingredients okay got it
yeah all right so Talia let's start with
you what do you got so you guys know how
much I love coffee so today I'm making a
latte quarantine so first I breed some
coffee then I added a little cream into
the coffee along with some ice creams to
cool it down
of course I added some Irish whiskey
into it because that's my favorite if I
add a cocktail shaker I'll just use that
but I don't
unfortunately whoa that looks amazing
yummy good pick me up all right Dylan
what about you okay well I just brewed
some iced tea the other day and I still
have a bunch of lemon so I'm gonna do a
kind of lemon ice tea quarantine so
first I had to make a quick simple syrup
with just sugar and water once I stir
that together and have it bubble I'll
let that cool and then build the drink
[Music]
Briony xro a good dog yeah that's some
tea bags and lemon I'm gonna have to try
to make that oh yeah it's so easy for
now I have another idea because I have
some leftover basil and the fridge it's
on its last leg so I'm gonna use that
and make a simple leftover herb and the
citrus corn tini so I'm gonna start by
juicing a full lemon I'm using basil and
lemon but you can really use whatever
leftover herbs and citrus that you have
on hand in a blender you're gonna throw
together the herbs the lemon juice some
honey a little bit of water and ice and
then you're gonna strain that whole
mixture after you blend it
[Music]
that sounds so refreshing I love the
color too
what did you make of it well I'm taking
a more indulgent route for this one so
I'm making more of like a dessert
cocktail I've got all the right
ingredients for it so get ready for the
s'mores Quarantine so first I got to
make the graham cracker rim with some
chocolate syrup and crushed up graham
crackers then to a shaker I'm gonna add
some bourbon but I'm sure any whiskey or
even realm would work here gonna add
some Irish cream a little bit of
chocolate syrup and some ice shake that
up pour it into your rims martini glass
and of course a s'mores Quarantine II
wouldn't be complete without a
marshmallow so I'm just going to toast
mine right over the stove and garnish it
like so until we all meet again in
person cheers everybody
[Music]
you
[Music]